this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman I'll be the
show on Friday with my buddy JT writes
Daniel s what do you go with Daniel s
hey your phrase is another Daniel in the
room they might be confused with Daniel
R he's getting married next month
Oh which one's JT you're JT you're
getting married next month
Kevin Smith says don't do it I heard I
heard I'm gonna show say that talk this
[ __ ] into it would you have
I was hoping Bruce Springsteen could
give him some helpful advice on how to
have a long just a long successful
marriage yeah the boss could tell you
something give me a little on stage vamp
Bruce Springsteen long story music we
got anything
[Music]
you know I'll tell you GT funny man you
asking for marriage advice I remember
back when I was walking the boardwalk
Jersey I had a buddy of mine II he was
about to get married to and he said hey
Bruce you have any advice for me it's
not said I don't know man I never been
married myself but I know a thing or two
about the ladies and I told him what I
thought about the institution of
marriage and he said I didn't know what
the [ __ ] I was talking about so I gave
him one of those big double-handed chest
shoves he tumbled backwards hit his head
on the railing of the boardwalk he hit
the ground pretty hard
[Music]
he was dead I didn't mean to push him
that hard it was an accident
Clarence said it didn't help the five
bullets I pumped into him afterwards
that was an accident too so Clarence and
I we threw my buddy in the back trunk of
my car we drove out to swamps of Jersey
tied him up with some rope and some
sandbags about a nice soft bog threw his
lifeless corpse into it Clarence and I
swore in that day then we'd never tell
another soul I just realized there's no
statute of limitations on murder
[ __ ] all right that's enough of that
that's an end
[Applause]
you
[Music]